aménagement toujours cette fois-ci on
vous parle d'un quartier de 10 hectares
qui s'apprête à sortir de terre dans le
centre ville de Tours le projet du futur
quartier des anciennes casernes Beaumont
a été dévoilé à la presse et au
riverains hier soir
780 logements de trois niveaux maximum
ou la végétation aura évidemment toute
sa place présentation détaillée avec
Florent Clavel
aujourd'hui c'est une dent creuse en
centre-ville avec ses casernes
emblématiques demain un quartier
flambant neuf où se met l'habitat et
collent les lieux culturels
dévoiler pour la première fois hier au
riverains sous forme de maquette le
futur quartier des Beaumont fait forte
impression c'est un beau projet d'autant
que je suis tourangelle depuis plus de
25 ans et les casernes ça fait un moment
qu'elles sont en attente on va dire 10
ans de réflexion en fait pour un projet
d'ampleur
780 logements vont sortir de terre dont
une centaine de logements sociaux les
premiers seront situés dans l'îlot 14
avec ses quatre grands bâtiments
un projet repris à la racine par la
nouvelle municipalité afin d'apporter
plus de verres à l'ensemble validé
c'était de réécrire avec la population
un quartier du 21e siècle donc il soit
compatible qui puisse résister qui soit
adapté aux dérèglement climatique en
particulier donc avec une architecture
bioclimatique avec des matériaux
biosourcés avec beaucoup d'espace
plantés le quartier comprendra également
une école un tiers-lieux situé dans les
casernes et déjà ouverts le futur Centre
chorégraphique national de Tours le tout
desservi par la ligne 2 du tramway et
équipée de parkings en silo en somme un
quartier moderne et facile à vivre pour
ses habitants selon l'architecte en
charge du projet et sentir bien parce
qu'ils pourront c'est d'un endroit à
l'autre en étant protégé de la chaleur
parce qu'ils entendront le vivant non
humain les animaux les oiseaux qui se
trouvont bien dans ces espaces et puis
il se trouveront bien entre humains
aussi parce qu'il y a plein d'endroits
des parvis des places des plages jardin
sur lesquels il y aura beaucoup
d'animation et qui vont rendre ce
quartier vivant d'un coup de plus de 30
millions d'euros le projet est quasi
intégralement financé par la vente des
terrains aux promoteurs c'est l'un
virgule 7 millions restant à la charge
de la ville de Tours les premiers
logements sont livrés d'ici deux ans